the audi a4 is a familiar sight on
German streets but this is no ordinary a
four it has all-wheel drive and bears
Audi's trademark quattro meaning all
four wheels are powered so it's a cut
above the ordinary but by no means a
secret the quattro is a tried and tested
car howdy presented the first quattro 36
years ago and it's been a success story
ever since the Colorado does poison
Audi's Florian cloud tells us more the
quattro began in nineteen eighty with
the open center differential in 1987
came the first self locking center
differential which has been continually
optimized over the years wheel drive
systems have seen many improvements
since then the latest generation
features what Audi calls ultra
technology the plan couple I'm in dark
floor and cold explains when the
decoupler is closed in the rear axle
transmission the electronically
controlled multi-plate clutch provides
variable torque distribution and
distributes power to the front and wheel
axles just as the situation demands to
switch to fuel efficient front-wheel
drive you have to open the multi-plate
clutch then you open the decoupler in
the rear axle transmission wanna vomit
nothing depresses the spring de modelo
now the all-wheel system is disengaged
once the V coupler is open the entire
drivetrain to the rear stops this
minimizes drag loss and generates
fuel-efficient front-wheel drive in
front between
the interplay between the newly
developed or wheel components and a
sophisticated operating strategy makes
the Quattro even more efficient the
intelligent steering works employs
predictive analytics using sensors that
evaluate data on driving dynamics road
conditions and driver behavior as a
result the all-wheel drive is always
ready when it's needed in the majority
of circumstances that Quattro operates
in front-wheel drive mode which help
save fuel
I think system can flow and kolb says
this system engages the all-wheel drive
within two tenths of a second or two
hundred milliseconds when it's needed
and the driver doesn't even notice it to
demonstrate he cruises in front-wheel
drive at 100 ma 20 kilometres an hour
now when he presses the gas pedal the
all-wheel-drive engages even before the
talk is on the wheels before this moment
you will help them innovative if he then
continues to cruise along the system
returns to front wheel drive the rear
axle transmission slows and stops and
the efficient front wheel drive is in
charge again I'll still off steam to
blow on dish nuts DF its hands for Tyler
from funky dreamin on people the old
wheel drive uses a three-step strategy
in the proactive stage the sensors relay
data to the cars network systems that's
what the steering apparatus uses for
example when the car goes into a fast
curve it then calculates the point where
the front inside wheel approaches the
limit of grip in predictive mode the
cuatros control system determines which
drive system to engage depending on
driving behavior the selected driving
mode and whether the car is pulling a
trailer in the reactive stage the system
responds to sudden changes in friction
between the tires and the road for
example when the car moves from dry to
wet pavement
the upstream under Lauren says Audi's
philosophy is to always coordinate the
all-wheel system in the same way in
Sweden the company tests both the self
locking center differential and the
system with actively controlled torque
distribution on low friction surfaces as
well as on high friction test circuits
this is always done with all the safety
systems deactivated to get an optimal
assessment of the all-wheel and 12
distribution systems so the calibrated
interaction among the various systems
offered by Audi is always the same the
test phase in Sweden is already
completed cuatros new wheel drive with
ultra technology will soon go into
series production
you